[Music]
recording
recording that would give us a good
enough start all right
hello you are listening to the plastic
pills
podcast the pill pod and plastic pills
this is a bonus episode which i
think we're gonna use to do some deep
dives uh in topics that people might be
interested related to critical theory
and philosophy so with me today this is
going to be sort of an
interview style i have hachik
how you doing not too bad how are you
should i call you hachik
chris is fun chris okay chris why don't
you tell me
what is the title of this episode gonna
be i know a little bit about your work
and it's in vitalism
is that a good episode title
i would say roughly speaking
dynamism organism and um
uh vitalism yes but why don't we name
the topic
uh dynamic life vital materialisms of
the past and present or just you know
vital material vital materialisms of the
past and present
i hope you will not begrudge me
something a little shorter
i would just say how about vitalism
today all right all right now we're
getting there so obvious first question
uh what is vitalism i would think that
there'd be multiple answers for this but
um
the clearest definition i would say
is really just a philosophy of life what
is life
how do we think about the concepts of
life
and um what is
what does it mean for things to be alive
and in movement
and i think that would be roughly what
vitalism is about
okay we have that word in there vital so
vitalism the philosophy of life and uh
if we're gonna name like the big few
thinkers
that are associated with vitalism
uh which would they be i'm actually
learning about this
too because i'm not very familiar with
it so
uh i'm not asking these questions just
to be rhetorical
oh no no i think i think that's a good i
think that's a
a good way of approaching this topic i
would say
you know it now it's very um i mean
people this is
a kind of polemical tradition i would
say that you know
the very first vitalist would be someone
like aristotle
and it could you could even say someone
like delivers
um gilda's the french philosopher would
be a vitalist
right and aristotle of course the
ancient greek philosopher and he
if i remember correctly he did a lot of
uh experiments like on animals and
studying them and classifying them
yes yes um his main work that
you know um we can give reference to is
on the anima on the soul and the main
the main task that the vitalists look at
is is
is animals and plants and how they have
a how there's a vegetable soul
and how there's an animal soul and so
this is where the vitalists look at
a kind of organic reading of of
individuals but
back to your question i would say de les
i would say bergson
um hans drish is a big one right now
jane bennett the
american philosopher who's a vitalist
uses him a lot
and there's other adaptations of
readings like spinoza
um the portuguese jewish philosopher who
talked about
the will as a conatis a striving to be
right these are all kind of um uh
life and movement concepts okay okay so
we you mentioned aristotle to start with
obviously he
classifies all these different animals
according to
you know their qualia and which ones
stand up right and all that stuff which
ones are social i think i remember him
talking about bees and stuff like that
um and then there's dillas who's on
about the concept of the rhizome which
obviously is a plant
um but how do those other philosophers
fit in because i don't recall spinoza
talking about plants
that's a really good question so the the
main text
that is used is by a german philosopher
and
actually um embryologist hans drish and
he has a philosophy text that
that all of your viewers can actually
read online it's called
an archive.org it's called towards a
philosophy
and history of vitalism and what's
interesting after and i'll put that in
the description
sure and what drish does is he he maps
out a clear distinction
that goes from let's say aristotle so
antiquity um to about i'd say
even as late as um
19 late 18th and 19th centuries so
up to um people like killmeyer
and and um lorenz awkin
and we'll talk about those a little bit
later with the medieval arkham
no oaken sorry lorenzo he's a okay
yeah um so we're talking about life um
plants and animals are an example of
life but it sounds like when you're
talking about spinoza
and these uh kind of idealist sort of
thinkers you're talking about something
that's
under the actual instantiation of life
and maybe something about life more
generally could we go in that direction
of course we can so just just a little
little little clear distinction here
aristotle when he's talking about the
soul for for plants
um and animals will say that they can
nurture themselves and that they have
enough to
and that they can take like you know so
photosynthesis aerosol takes as a as a
principle of
of semi intelligence for plants however
in the
in the case of in the case of spinoza
what makes spinoza
oddly vitalistic or life-centered
is in the third book of his his magnum
opus the ethics
where he talks about the will as a
striving to be
okay now this is going to be a main
concept in the history of vitalism
and in modern philosophy right now that
that's anyone that's doing eco-criticism
or anyone that's doing any work in
in neo-vitalism we'll always talk about
this main some concept of the connatus
right
and what the konatis stands for is
meaning will
yes yes so it's not just a will con it's
not just a concept about the will it's
the idea
of this striving right this kind of
struggling through moving through right
and not just
simple locomotion it has to they have
there has to be a certain amount of
obstacles so via particulars objects
that are offering some kind of
resistance against
a specific life form and them adapting
to that
obstacle and that would be the the pure
essence of life
so we could imagine something like a
tree growing and the tree is trying to
find the area of the best sunlight and
sort of reaching up
to the sky in that way would that be an
expression of that
konatu's will yes so this is an
excellent example and and your tree
example is perfect because someone like
a modern thinker that maybe the
listeners have read before is jane
bennett
and bennett talks about um
non-human forms of life so a tree would
be a perfect
perfect example because yes what does a
tree do a tree
um will actually slant to the far side
to reach up and grab sunlight right um
trees also
in with in regards to their roots send
off apparently
this is what so-called scientists are
saying right now they send off some kind
of
information to weed off weeds and bugs
or whatever
um but any this kind of moving away from
obstacles or or
this struggling to be is a kind of
konatis and jane bennett's
um work what she's trying to promote is
this example of conatus can be extended
to not just humans but to even
metals and plastics believe it or not
okay okay so we're generalizing will
pretty far here as this uh yeah the
the concept of kanadu sounds very
general
yes yes so it's not it's not just like a
human subject
makes a decision they're saying no this
sort of uh
force like will belongs not only to
plants and animals but also
to plastic yes um jane bennett
will openly state that uh human beings
are walking talking minerals so
even extending uh and this is extending
this idea of konatus to the minerals and
bacteria in your intestines okay so it's
a very
non-anthropocentric philosophy vitalism
and this is what it's meant to do right
it's meant to de-center
you can think of it as a as a as moving
man away from the center of the
copernican revolution
right okay so just to reiterate the
copernican revolution is
taking man from the very center of
the universe saying no the man is on the
earth
or a man's on the earth which orbits the
sun then we find out the sun's not the
center of the universe
yes yes so this is a copernican
revolution in philosophy
is that kind of the analogy yes it's
it's a kind of
de-centering of the anthropo
anthropomorphism of
human knowledge now that word
anthropomorphism you know
morph meaning form anthro meaning man
the the form of man
us us kind of making everything into an
image for ourselves
it's a movement away from that kind of
rationality or that thinking
so it's a non-humanism also sounds like
or
post post-humanism even maybe it's it's
definitely a post-humanism for sure
yes okay um and this sounds like
particularly relevant today when we're
dealing with issues
of you know environmental destruction
and
the way that we react to the world very
often is
in a very mechanistic or mechanical
understanding of it where we don't
really
give a i don't know a value to things
that are not
thinking conscious in the way that we
are
it's it's so funny that you say that
because this idea of mechanism is where
vitalism started
so in the 15th in the 15th century as um
the great french philosopher will say
kenya him will say
that human beings like to use
analogies of technology to describe
phenomena in the world so like think
about you know
the example of the cosmos we like to
break down the universe into simple
parts
and we compare it to a clock or
something but in
in reality the universe isn't clockwork
and has simple parts right
so this idea of breaking down a
phenomena into
some form of technology or technological
object or
some some kind of object right it it
removes the kind of organic feature
from that substance and so this is what
happened in the 15th century with a
with a i'm going to use a big word here
ietrophysics
and and this doctrine was about
mathematizing the world
okay so what what these people did was
they started to look at
the advancements in science and the
mathematic and mathematics
and start to uh
look at the that living living matter
as as simple objects breaking them down
to the smallest parts
yeah so the every little bit of
uh interaction that happens or these
billiard balls kind of bouncing around
the galilean
kind of thesis absolutely okay
absolutely
and vitalism is trying to bring a
unifying force that's saying no you
can't just look at every particular
interaction you've got to look at
the overall canadus
yes absolutely so extending that concept
of konadus
to every kind of living form and and
looking at things
not just from the human perspective so
not looking at
uh the earth exam for for example as an
object that you can break down
into the furniture of space or something
like that
um you know how philosophers talk about
objects in the world as furniture as
taking up space
this would be a very mechanical way of
looking at at the world
right because there are other things out
there that are in ecosystems and they're
connected together the earth the soil
the
the air the oxygen etc i mean i'm just
giving broad examples here but
well this sounds like a very reflective
almost
um a minor philosophy an
anti-the dominant western trend of
are trends of empiricism and rationalism
so
the uh we would you call this like an
anti-hume
version or did hume is hume kind of on
the bubble edge here
oh no hume would definitely be a
mechanical philosopher okay because
hume definitely sees um things
in regards to how humans you know break
the world down to constant conjunction
and contiguity and
causality etc right so this is a
rebellion philosophy
almost a minor philosophy okay it would
be it a total rebellion
um and actually the funniest thing about
this is you know alchemy everyone talks
about the philosopher's stone and all
these things because of
something like harry potter or something
but alchemy was actually
the first form of of um
of vitalism talking to trying to take
you know elixirs and medals and making
them into
uh you know a science of knowing living
matter
so this is okay great that's a that's a
good example so
um is there any are there any thinkers
around this time that you could
mention that people might have heard
that are like standing for this vitalist
tradition
the the funny the funny thing is that
hans drish names the first vitalist of
the early modern era as leibniz
because what is life what does leibniz
do livenitz takes the
the the monism of spinoza and turns it
into a spiritual substance that's
all interconnected with these other
monads that are already contained with
all that they need
living in one kind of pre-established
harmony
so he sees this as the first step into
a kind of pre-vital stage
so why don't you give me the one main
vitalist thinker that you think
people should read if they're interested
in this okay well i'm going to be a
little biased here and and use the
french
thinker uh maine de barron or mandi
bergen okay
and the reason why i'm picking him is
because the french school of
montpellier really got the entire
philosophy of vitalism moving and the
reason why it did that is because
at the time in montpellier there was a
medical school
that was trying to use philosophy to
both heal
psychologically the mind and the body
and so the vitalist movement started
looking at
um living beings like ourselves first
and and realizing that a true being
is expresses oneself so this
expressivity
which you know was a maxim to live is to
feel
became the kind of um uh vitalist
mantra of this period and so we have
these these um
medical doctors like theophilie de
bordeaux
um and joseph barces who are
talking about forces and
invisible intensities and and principles
that are
helping shape that help shape uh
life and help shape um what he calls a
singularity or
an individual principle that is aiding
this momentum of life forward
i'm finding all this really interesting
because this is happening in the context
of basically the scientific revolution
and the scientific revolution is trying
to medicalize
the body turn the body into you know
kind of sort of the way that we think
about it
today and they're doing experiments
breaking things down
into cause and effect
fragmenting nature into these component
parts and you're saying what vitalism is
doing
is this counter current at while the
same time all this is happening
they're saying no we want to look at
holes and we want to look at
um the way that life expresses itself
through bodies as a like a whole
organism
so it would be fair to characterize this
as uh
try to glue up the cracks
that the scientific revolution the uh
scientific method is
kind of bringing onto nature absolutely
right so what they
what they do to counter that um
revolution is
to try to create a science of man um
sorry
i'll be gender neutral here a science of
human life
and and what that is is they want to
really focus on
on action movement and feeling and now
you know that
you know it's not not just humans
do these things right you know plant
life moves
animal life moves there's certain
feeling whether it's
um instinct or habit or not i mean
that's another story but
they're looking at these three things
action movement and feeling
and they're governing these three
principles under
what they call the science of men or the
science of human life
all right there's one word i want to ask
you about and i think it'll probably
help us get to
more of a concrete notion of vitalism or
an anti-concrete notion but i've heard
this word associated with vitalism
that is in french elon vitale
do you want to explain that yes um
okay so it's so funny that you bring
this up because this is a concept this
french concept is taken from
uh bergson and
bergson is also taking this concept he's
using it in a a way against someone like
leibniz and spinoza the konatus
right we had this idea of konatus but
really what bergson uses
this meaning of elan vital goes all the
way back to aristotle and aristotle's
concept of movement in life was called
entelicia
and so for bergson there's a kind of
spiritual
um living force right that's
vibrating within uh living matter
and and he saw this as the kind of um
he saw this as the as you said before
the glue or the synthesis that brought
the ideal world and the material world
together and he
you know he extends this into the
conceptions of time but that's
going a little too further and we like
bergson of course he's on the good team
because
deliz wrote a full book on him and then
references him almost all over the place
so he's the delusion team
the minor philosophy team but now that
we're
now that we're talking about bergson or
or even this idea of elon vitale it's
really
the translation of that sorry chris is
it just vital force or a living force
that's exactly what a force means vital
force okay yeah
and it's really important that we we
take up this idea of the vital force or
the living force and and back to that
school of montpellier
they still had that concept as well
while they were doing
medical medical philosophy absolutely
keep in mind this is that this i mean a
hundred years prior to this lee van hoek
was looking at
um you know living organisms via a tel
um
microscope and people started to think
about a kind of living ether within
within all um human and animal and plant
life and so we were thinking about what
is this
and you know it you could roughly
theologic
make this theological and say it's the
soul but really they're talking about
almost back to aristotle an anima a
principle of activation
actuality right and this is what you
know we can talk about in regards to
bergson and
everyone else this living force i have a
question for you then if
could we include heidegger into this
vitalist tradition because he's very
much opposed
to the way that modern humans see
nature as this resource so you know we
see a tree we want to cut it down
we see a river we want to build a dam
over it and get electricity out of it
and says return to this like being
with nature could you call heidegger a
vitalist in that context or is he
on a different in a different school or
category well there's two things here
um and it's a really great question
because heidegger is used a lot
and so like um for our listeners that
are are
open-minded to object-orientated
ontology and speculative realism
heidegger is used a lot for
eco-criticism and criticism of how we
have
how we technolog technologize the world
or we
in frame the world so yes in a weird way
heiliger is kind of like a
proto-vitalist
but he doesn't believe in the living the
living force or
um he actually divides the world and the
earth up right
only dazn or human beings are in the
world
while the stone and the animal are
worldless they're in the earth
um that's so we're going even less
anthropocentric
than even heidegger and heidegger's
whole project was to be less
anthropocentric
right so we're going we're almost on the
borderline of
saying that matter is life as well too
and and you know whitehead does
things like that you know the english
philosopher alfred north whitehead
talked about a kind of pen psychism
whitehead is also on the good team
because
de los writes books on him
but back to this idea of like a living
force
um and this is a good idea to go back
into the french school for a second and
bergson's a part of this as well
okay too right bergson's a part of this
french school the school of montpellier
got closed down actually
it got closed down by paris scientists
and medical doctors
that were feuding with montpellier
because they thought vitalism itself was
was alchemy and hokey pokey and it got
shut down
and interestingly enough the last the
last
doctrine that came out of the paris
institute
was phrenology which became a racial
rule
which became a racialized skull
so maybe they needed vitalism the entire
time that's the funny thing about it
um but back to this idea of the living
force now there's two things we really
need to get down to
you know it's so funny um the
theological philosopher meister eckhart
says
before we have an abode we must abide
meaning before you can live in the world
before you can be yourself you need to
live in the world
so what what are the what is this idea
here and so what we get to is a concept
of habit
habitat and habit they are just
they're almost synonymous in the sense
that a habit
in terms of in in the term yeah
in the term of aristotle hexis is a
disposition no virtue
and to save thomas aquinas it's a
disposition a cloth
something that can be covered and so
with living matter they form
kind of habits because what's going on
in the world is
they're attracting certain stimulus
right
they're meeting resistance forces
so this is where the 18th century
vitalism takes up this idea of force
obstacles um intensities
you were gonna ask a question yeah um
well habit
we have to distinguish in the the term
we're not talking about like biting your
nails
habit we're not talking about we're not
talking about doing the same thing over
and over again we're talking about this
uh
habit in terms of the cloth more like so
it's something that you
almost put on right yeah oddly is that
right
or is it put on you or do you is it put
on you or you put it on
you put the cloth on yes but i mean in
terms of this habit as a philosoph as a
philosophical term
oh it would be like a covering covering
okay yeah
but the funny thing is that bergson
actually likes hume and the reason why
he likes hume is because hume
breaks apart the subject and just talks
about
a human being as a a bundle of sense
data so when you think of habits as this
bundle of phenomena
or sense data it's interesting because
you can now
um impart that bundle to other living
forces now this is not what hume says
having trouble with this so is that okay
sorry is the bundle theory
habit what's the connection between
those two because you said putting on
which i got
and he said bundle theory which i think
some people
probably probably understand but how do
those two connect
that's a really good question so um
now getting into heart now we're going
to get into the nitty-gritty now the
hardcore
vitalist stuff okay so
habit is formed in two ways according to
the vitalist
passivity and activity now
passivity is a concept that occurs when
you
when you meet some form of resistance
that you've had
um that repeats itself so repetition so
you know your daily
benign routine where you get up in the
morning you brush your teeth you're
walking through
and you're not really paying attention
but you're so you're on autopilot
yes you know when you're and this is
called pacific passivity
this is passivity so oddly you're not
doing any form of expression you're not
expressing yourself there's no form of
resistance that's
actualizing you know the the intensities
or the
the living force inside you and so what
happens is you start contracting
stimuli that makes you act a certain way
because you're on autopilot
so for the vitalist this is a this is a
movement towards mechanization
okay and a movement away from from
um uh the organism the organic right
and so it's not it's not fulfilling the
act of the will or
the the konatu is here right so you're
not really yourself
when you're just going going through a
day-to-day everyday routine
right so i mean so you can see some you
can now see some residences here with
heidegger right like this would be
you know being absorbed into the world
and the they and et cetera et cetera so
you can see
so you were you weren't wrong when you
brought up heidegger
um so let's get to activity then
yes so activity is when you actualize
something when you
when you are fully willing to do
something when your connatus
is is emerged in movement where there's
actual resistance real resistance and
you start
um activating certain things so
right now like a simple example you and
i are on a podcast right now
we're not this is my first time being on
a podcast so i don't know if i'm being
terrible or not
so i know you're not paying attention
i'm not being passive here i'm being
quite active because i have to think
about your responses
your questions can sometimes throw me
off right i have to
be listening and ready to answer what
you're going to say and i have to think
about these things so i'm
i'm in a weird sense i'm getting
used to i'm kind of feeling i'm
comforting myself and by comporting by
behaving a certain way
i'm acting against the resistance of my
of
the questions or whatever right so
struggling
i mean this is a basic principle that
everyone's familiar with
struggle is good for life struggle makes
you stronger survival of the fittest
but this is giving it a positive spin
not like it's a competitive environment
but
you become more yourself and more your
own form
or not not just you as a person but a
tree say a tree that has to survive a
drought
is a lot stronger than a tree that's
watered on a golf course or something
um yes yes so they like the vitalists
like this sense of
activity overcoming resistance the tree
that has to find the sun
uh the tree that survives the the storm
or whatever
you know manuel manuel delanda who's
another good source another neo-vitalist
i would say
he's been he's been put into the ooo
camp but i really consider him as a
violence because
what is the main concept he talks about
expressivity
right so how living phenomena express
themselves within the contours of
resistance
is itself a living struggle it's a
living phenomena right this is
part of a vitalism so if we could
if i could try to simplify this one more
time with the storm example we would
if we had a mechanistic view then we'd
say something like oh yeah well the tree
is its roots are deep enough to give it
enough leverage to stop the wind from
blowing it over
and that's just what's happening there's
nothing interesting in this in this
relationship
but if we look at it from the vitalist
perspective the tree
is actually being a tree
by just resisting and expressing that
word that you said
expressing its resistance against
the elements that are trying to you know
push it over
i i think that's a good example yeah
because i really like that that kind of
brings some uh
enchantment and fascination back to the
world instead of seeing things as
just cause and effect you see you know
life
struggling against uh the elements that
are opposed against
opposed to it and this is that idea of
living force right this is the trees
elon
it that that the way that it can comport
itself in
in the storm the way that it it stands
it stands firm it's absorbing
energy from light etc it right there's
this mode of expressivity here
and you can see why a lot of people in
the left
um i'll give you an example um
[Music]
the proto marx will not proto the
marxist scholar peter halward he
considers
vitalism to be dangerous and i i've i've
had conversations with hollywood before
and he
doesn't like this idea of vitalism
because he thinks it's a
d centers this human subject and b it
gets too spiritual and
and let's hold hands in kumbaya right
right so it's very
it's very anti-political if what you're
looking for is a political revolution
because it's saying you know take a walk
and
observe how the plants are growing
rather than you know
pick up your placard and storm the
bastille
yeah but you know the funny thing about
that is is that like jane bennett's book
vibrant matter she
she looks at the greek word for politics
polite
which really means the pivot the pivot
of
of of people so if you take that idea of
the pivot
and you think about a polite of living
animals
and and plants then there is a kind of
politics or a republic of living
organisms right
that are not just human-centered so
there is a kind of
odd politics going on in in in plant
life and animal life
what what do you what does she mean when
she says the
politics means pivot i thought it was
like uh the polis the greek city state
yeah she has this um this argument about
uh
how the and i think she gets this from
heidegger too this idea that the
that the real greek understanding of
uh politics is somehow a polite
which is a pivot a pivot of of a of a
community or or
a community dispersed with with um or
teaming she says
she uses the word teaming with life i
think it's interesting i i don't i don't
know that part
i've never read um the book that you're
talking about
uh but it would be interesting to find
out how she
provides an alternative etymology um so
i mean this is an interesting point to
bring up though that it's vitalism is
criticized for being
anti-political but uh
because i know a little bit about
neo-vitalism
they would say that's not really true
right because they are bringing it into
eco-criticism or the criticism of
not uh environmental concerns i guess
and do you want to talk at all about any
of those thinkers that are
bringing vitalism into discussions
of you know i don't know global warming
or
or whatever issues they're bringing up
over there
yeah and a lot of these a lot of these
scholars are broadly
in the the stream of speculative realism
and
andelus studies but can i just make a
minor point here for one second yeah
sure
um just back to one idea of science so
the first the vitalists the 19th and
20th century were all embryologists
believe it or not
and up to about the early 19th century
an embryologist
of course someone who studies embryos of
animals that are still gestating or
something like that
yes so they're physical scientists at
this point
yes they're physical scientists so we're
talking real
a real close connection still between
science and philosophy at this time
in history absolutely and even the j and
the funny thing about the german
vitalists like someone like blumenbach
had a concept called the building
bildungstribe
which is the sexual drive the the
energies that
that help produce the the egg
now this is something that delize brings
up he talks about the idea that when a
um when an embryo when an embryo is
fertilized it shatters apart in a
thousand pieces and then is
pulled together and the forces that are
pulling it back together
connected and and it's virtual and
actual and it's connected now i just
wanted to bring up this idea that
they are still working within a
semi frame of science um
yeah so when we're talking about this
abstract force i mean
peter peter hallward said it as you
mentioned it kind of gets abstract and
takes us out of the political world so
if you could concretize this like these
uh
early scientists did what kind of
examples could you give
well there's really there's two great
examples the first is
is by hans drish who's an embryologist
focusing his study on the embryo and
up to the early 19th century human
scientists still believe that
the male sex had something called an
ana molecule which was both the fetus
and the sperm together and that the womb
somehow in the woman was just an empty
rock and
and it just was there a place holder and
i'm so during the second
the egg and the sperm travel from the
from the male into the empty female
so she's just a negative subject
if you if you read um leibniz's theodicy
chapter three he brings up this idea of
antimolecules and it's and
i'm laughing here and i'm not trying to
laugh um to be insane
insensitive i'm laughing because it took
up to it took these vitalists
focused on the concept of life to really
figure this concept out
and to actually give back um two women
another kind of anima another living
force as well because there's two forces
here being
conjoined to form a child right but two
two sex seeds
or two sex cells sorry um and it
and it was it was blumenbach who who saw
that within the connection between
the ovum and the sperm there was some
kind of bildungsribe
a sexual drive an another elan vital
that was passed through the cells
that are helping help shape the
formation of of a fetus
so sex and just gestation is a good
example of this
elan vital inaction i guess yeah and the
concept they call and they call this
concept epigenesis right okay
epi meaning alongside the prefix and
genesis meaning
the origin so you got a dual origin
yup you got it um i find it interesting
that at this time
all of these they're philosophers you're
calling them philosophers but they're
also doing
physical science so i think that in some
ways should uh
dissuade us of this presumption that you
know science deals with
the matters of the earth and philosophy
deals with the matters of heaven or
something
like that so they're doing both and
they're figuring out their philosophy
while they're actually working with
these embryos and stuff
yeah no oh absolutely um
okay but we could all we could just
think about things like trees
as the cilan vital and you said some of
the other philosophers are extending it
even
further so could you call i don't know a
river would that have elon vital would
you
would that be your position yes so
i'll even give you a concrete example so
um blumenbach
and another german thinker wolf
had a concept called the vis
essentialists now the vis
essentialist is the the origin of how
these epigenetic
forces emerge in organic matter and they
promote the binding of complex
structures right so like
blumenbach uses the concept to frame a
kind of vitalist interpretation of
generation
and so the the this essentialist serves
kind of like the
elan vital it's a power by which
nutritive material
is distributed to various parts of a
plant
right of plant formation even though
this happens just this happens through
something like osmosis but they're
ascribing the elan vital even to that
process where like liquid is moving
between cells
okay yeah so this process is is
is behind the kind of organic epigenesis
that is
you know help stabilizing the regular
structural pattern of generation
so we can see elan vital in
in many different types of interaction i
guess is the point
uh yes and we should be and we should be
looking for it in those places
and this is why i mean now we can bring
this to you know
more kong like more core theories now
this is why there's been a
you know a rush of scholarship to people
like
reading de luz and and um bergson again
because what de lewis does and delis
says very
very prominently that he writes for
for those that have no voice and
who doesn't have a voice but the earth
right
um so um
i think one thing is important is that
when we start looking at
how organic matter is related to us
deliz likes to look at things as a
territory so his
great example from a thousand plateaus
for those
those listeners at home that like the
liz he
he brings up this great example about
birds
and how birds will start
will formulate their will reform their
nest by taking a series of
objects around by their why they want to
make their nest
they pull this nest together and this
organic territory
right is not just a home
a habitat it's a kind of vibrant
space for them right it's it's it's
supple there
it helps them maintain their food
supports
foods food source it it supplies them
shelter but
also it's organic enough for them to
raise their youth
uh for them um to be situated so they
have a more
there's a more con um there's a there's
a stronger organic continuity here
is what he's bringing up so it's a more
organic process compared to how
humans would build a house which would
be
you know buy the land from the bank with
a deed
bring up bring an architectural map
um design the building not not with
the land in mind they're not living in
the land they're not
building the house around the land it's
kind of this imposition
cookie cutter get your mcmansion you
know dig it out compared to this bird
process which is
living i guess more harmoniously and
more organically
in its environment compared to the way
that we do i liked
i like the word you use there you use
the word harmonious
in exactly right back to live and it
says pre-established
harmony this is this is a kind of
animal attunement here right it's it's
it's a form of expressivity like
think about birds that reflect
themselves in during mating
you know who have expressed themselves
with
great you know flamboyant colors that
are you know
doing dances in an odd sense to attract
a mate
they bring this this organic this
organic ritual incorporates the world
around them and they're like flashing
their feathers and their feathers
have this relation to the food that
they've eaten so you can see this all as
like this expressivity of nature itself
absolutely yeah yeah you're much more
clear than me
all right so um just to wrap this up
here i want to ask you
first i want to challenge you um what
would you say to the claim that this is
all just
some hippie kumbaya [ __ ]
you know i i struggle with this all the
time because when you tell
other academics that you're working on
vitalism the first thing they do is oh
so you're a historian yeah i'm like
does that yeah so tell us why you did
that and you know it's interesting
um one of my favorite thinkers is a man
named um ian hamilton grant and
and he's a neo-vitalist but he uses
non-violence thinkers to think about how
we can create a modern conception of
nature
because what we do is according to grant
is we create something called physiocide
and physiocide is where we kill nature
right
so we actually destroy it and if you
look at
um hegel's science of or encyclopedia to
the philosophy of nature
the first thing he says about nature is
that it's a product there for us to
consume
yeah and also i think i think uh what's
his name that it
the uh macchiavelli says something too
nature's a
nature is a [ __ ] and we should strap
her to the rack
and rape her um
unfortunately yes he wasn't talking
about but nature specifically but just
the the randomness of nature
um and that's kind of this modern
mindset right that nature is random
it must it should be controlled it
should be exploited for our value
and and obviously we see this
everywhere you don't have to go to
fracking which is the worst example but
just
generally we don't have this respect so
what i hear you saying
is that vitalism is important because it
kind of returns
this respect to you know the living
world around us that we're intimately
dependent on no matter how much we
forget that when we're
you know in the supermarket buying corn
that's wrapped in plastic
and meat that's wrapped in plastic right
when you think of the assembly line that
goes behind all of those products but
to think about nature according to ian
hamilton grant is to create a kind of
philosophy of nature
and so his form of attributing a new
step towards neo-vitalism is to create a
philosophy of nature now
to think of nature no longer as a
particular
but as a universal as something that is
here
that is a part of a kind of organic
totality
right that isn't just a part that makes
up the whole
but is kind of like a living um
a living substance we're always a part
of that and we don't have a choice about
it even though we can
do our best to forget it with you know
air conditioning
showers um streets
and then we plant you know little nature
band-aids and have public parks but
instead instead of this fragmentary
view which is the modern view get back
to a sense of wholeness
could we say re-enchanting nature a
little bit is what vitalism does
i i like that i like that it's kind of
like reappropriating max
labor right well disenchantment is just
this
a constant theme in my
personal philosophy which i've actually
never brought up before now but
disenchantment is this sense of
mourning that we have like morning with
a you
um a sadness that we don't know why
we're feeling
and i think it has something to do with
this lack of respect or lack of
situatedness or habit
that you're talking about and i think
what i'm getting out of this
conversation is if we
had a better philosophy of life and a
better philosophy of
vital vitalism that's not just
privileging human
political subjects then maybe we would
have less of this sense of mourning
and disenchantment i like that idea
so why do you do why do you do it why
did you choose this out of all the
things that you could have chosen
and out of all the things that you're
actually good at good at
studying um
i originally wanted to study the subject
what a subject is and
the more that i started reading i
started reading um the french thinker
main de baron
and it was so interesting to me that
biron
would literally say something in his in
his work
that we're no longer a subject living in
passivity
we're an object but we're an object
because we've objectified ourselves
within that system already we're a
system of
of objects that are not harnessing the
power
of this he calls it the primitive fact
the
the living force within us right the at
the active side of
of of being in that in the world and
feeling that resistance wow so this is
really exciting because he's saying
privileging the human subject in a
humanist
sense is actually not giving us the
credit we deserve
he's saying that is actually making us
seem smaller than what we actually are
absolutely because that's a pretty
incredible insight instead we should see
ourselves as objects but these very
complicated objects that are full
of not just a brain and not just
rationality but
all of these forces that are going on
in our even our bodies at all times and
the interaction that we have with actual
organic matter every day when we're
eating
or or or water when we're drinking
and you know it's funny i'm going to
take it to an area that you're
you're more comfortable with with bruno
latour and whitehead
because i know you know them quite well
um and now i don't think there are
vitalists but let's look at the way that
they
think about the world and philosophy so
whitehead think about whitehead for a
second he sees
all things as entities right off the bat
he's removed the subject and object
relationship
he sees things as as a as a part of a
kind of dynamic process
right if you look at bruno latour what
does he do he looks for the depth
of actors right right away all things
are on a kind of balance on a balanced
level they're actors
as opposed to that's a tree in the mud
that's this that's that and that there's
a series of processes now
going on interacting right harping back
to jane bennett
vibrant matter right
and you should be we should be looking
for that presumably
i think so i think this is this for me
this is a way of
of moving away from the whole kantian
system
sorry to be jargony here just the
mechanical the mechanical system right
the mechanized way of doing philosophy
to move away from even a mechanical
way of viewing the world right
so instead of a clock it's more like
i don't know a forest
a clearing in the forest you know it's
it's really funny my favorite physicist
is leonard suskin and
all of his lectures by the way they're
on youtube so please go and watch them
they're amazing
but leonard suskin says something
interesting and he said this at a uni at
um
at a conference in toronto he said you
know what
physicists are up to too much right now
we need philosophers
we need philosophers to start thinking
about concepts of matter
so we can we can work with these
concepts
i think that's pretty profound for an
actual very established physicist to say
something like that
and i like him a lot as well too not
that that matters
but that there is a kind of you know
that they're
looking for a kind of integrated
relationship between philosophers and
scientists
i think that's a great way to bookend
this which is just
supposed to be an introduction so
thanks very much for being here chris
if someone was gonna say you know what
this really resonates with me this is
the kind of philosophy
i wanna do um but i don't know much
about philosophy
or i'm not i don't have time to read a
long
book by an obscure french thinker
what would be the source or a source or
somewhere that they could look just to
you know get their get in on getting on
the ground floor of this uh
movement philosophy i that's a great
question
and i'm going to give them a free source
okay and it's no copyright infringement
at all
it's archive.org look up hans drish
german philosopher and look for towards
a history
and philosophy of vitalism he goes from
aristotle which we did today
in your program all the way up to
bergson
of course i'll put that in the uh
episode description is it long or is it
short
it's it's not it's pretty long but it
you know the reader can get through
certain areas it's good
they'll enjoy it it's not that long okay
great anyway chris uh
thanks so much for being here uh to
the listeners this is the first
interview style thing that i've ever
done in my life so
if it's choppy um i apologize for that
but i
i would like to do this to just
interview not just my friends but
people who are studying uh i guess
minor philosophy is really what i'm i'm
into in in a very general sense so
um i hope you enjoyed it let me know
what you think
um and chris i'm sure we'll have you
back probably for some
your other area of expertise german
idealism
or your other area of expertise deliz
so we're gonna do one of those three
things later
well thank you very much for having me
and and uh and to the listeners out
there
um this pill pod is an excellent way of
you know brushing up your skills on
critical theory and
and a mixture of the theoretical and the
practical and and
you should give this a little a little
more of a listen it's good all right
thanks for having me
thanks thanks for the endorsement um
yeah
i plan to i plan to i want to go all
over the place i
just went a broad exposure to
every kind of idea that you could think
of um i
certainly don't know every everything
but i kind of know
like one or two words about a bunch of
different things
that i can at least drop like elaine
vitale i'm glad we got to that so i
could
i could i could show mine yeah we didn't
talk about the rhizome that's funny but
that's good another episode yeah we'll
do it dude
all right see you chris see ya
[Music]